si mal no recuerdo si la memoria no me
falla ya han pasado un par de meses
desde que subí la parte 3 de detalles en
videojuegos pero tengo una explicación y
es que estos vídeos no son fáciles de
hacer es decir ahí para mí sería fácil
ponerte un clip de lo impresionante que
serían los pezones de kratos o lo bien
que se ve esta piedra pero no a mí me
gusta dejar cierto tiempo entre cada uno
de estos vídeos para darles un toque
especial y así hacerlos cada vez mejor
me gusta profundizar más en esto
sumergirme en los detalles
[Música]
en fin bienvenidos a la parte 4 de
detalles en videojuegos una serie en
donde exploramos la gran atención al
detalle y dedicación que podremos
encontrar en algunos juegos pues sí como
ya ha de saber estas alturas me encantan
estos pequeños detalles
[Música]
y esta vez no tengo nada más que decir
así que me callo y comencemos con el
vídeo si lleva siguiéndome ya un tiempo
y conoces bastante el canal ya debes
saber que soy un hombre de cultura pues
a lo largo de la mayoría de mis vídeos
me encanta poner de vez en cuando
algunos memes en muchas ocasiones siendo
de 'bob esponja' porque como dije soy un
hombre de cultura pero algo que me canso
grassi es que al parecer no soy el único
que le gustan estas idioteces pues en el
remake del juego de 'bob esponja' que
salió en el 2020 hay un pequeño secreto
homenajeando la infinidad te menees que
la comunidad ha creado pues si decides
quedarte quieto por un tiempo su
personaje comenzará a recrear algunas de
las escenas más famosas de la serie
[Música]
la serie de videojuegos mafia es una
serie supremamente infravalorada pues
usualmente no se le da el crédito que
merece a pesar de ser creada por la
todopoderosa rockstar y obviamente
tratándose de rockstar estos juegos
prestan mucha atención a los pequeños
detalles que hacen que sus mundos se
sientan más vivos un gran ejemplo de
esto lo encontraremos en mafia 2 en
donde está la más simple nuestras
acciones tendrá algún tipo de
consecuencia pues en cierta parte del
juego jugaremos una misión en donde al
final entraremos en un drenaje y por
ende terminaremos hechos un asco al
terminar esta misión y antes de comenzar
la siguiente lo lógico sería que
limpiara a tu personaje para no andar
con ese olor a [ __ ] por todo el lugar
pero si por alguna extraña razón tú en
tu infinita sabiduría decides comenzar
la siguiente misión sin haber limpiado
tu personaje la parte inicial de la
misión cambiará
[Música]
un estrés
yo
why they can't be back to me completa
con augusto tenga millones aunque yo
creo que buena época stone raid para
gais offline y el lugar menos horas
[Música]
pero en lugar de una unidad para
disertar en turnos 59
el juego de los vengadores que salió en
2020 lastimosamente no logró llenar las
expectativas de la mayoría de personas
pues no llegó a hacer el juego que
esperaban es divertido y todo por le
faltó ese entusiasmo que caracteriza a
marvel pero lo que no les faltó desde
luego fueron referencias pues [ __ ]
puede que no tenga un buen juego pero
puedes estar jodidamente seguro de que
tendrás referencias el juego realmente
puso mucho empeño en muchos guiños y
detalles del universo marvel y uno de
los mejores lo podemos encontrar en la
base de los vengadores pues en la
habitación del sur encontraremos el
mejor nido es interactuamos con él
nuestro personaje tratará de levantarlo
pero obviamente ninguno podrá esto
podemos intentarlo con cualquier
personaje pero si lo intentamos con el
cap de manera muy parecida a lo que
vemos en la era de dhul throne el
capitán américa será el único en poder
mover ligeramente el martillo
[Música]
volvamos nuevamente a mafia esta vez a
mafia 3 otro juego que pudo haber sido
excelente pero no llego a hacer lo que
la gente esperaba y aunque es verdad que
el juego cometió muchos errores es
innegable el hecho de que la
ambientación del juego les quedó
excelente para los que no saben mafia 3
toma lugar a finales de los años 60 una
época en la que el racismo estaba muy
presente en eeuu y ya que nuestro
protagonista es afroamericano el mundo a
su alrededor lo tratará de manera
distinta por ejemplo cada vez que
nuestro personaje comete algún crimen
las personas normalmente llamarán a la
policía si cometes algún crimen en algún
barrio en donde habiten mayormente
personas de color esto es lo que dirán
way
ahora si cometes crímenes en barrios en
los que mayormente habiten personas
blancas dirán lo siguiente
[Aplausos]
como ven la policía no tiene ningún
interés en acudir a los barrios con
personas negras y no les dan mucha
importancia pero cuando se trata de
personas blancas se presentan
inmediatamente este es un gran detalle
que demuestra lo indignante que eran las
cosas en aquella época
[Música]
y al igual que yo eres una persona culta
lo que deberías estoy seguro que debes
conocer la saga de videojuegos del
príncipe de persia una de las mejores
trilogías de videojuegos de su época
el último juego de esta trilogía fue
principe de persia los dos tronos en
este juego las arenas del tiempo
comienzan a afectar la mente del
príncipe lo que causa con la
personalidad oscura se desarrolla en su
interior que sería como una versión
oscura del príncipe esta versión oscura
tiene un curioso sentido del humor pues
si durante el juego nos quedamos quietos
y no movemos al príncipe por un tiempo
su versión oscura comenzar a enojarse
con nosotros
esto me pareció genial considerando el
hecho de que el juego tiene más de 15
años ya y aún así se incluyeron pequeños
detalles como este
pocas historias han logrado crear un
sentimiento de peligro tan real como lo
hizo the last of us es una historia
donde sabes que en cualquier momento te
pueden enviar alguna todo en the last of
o representa un constante peligro lo
cual es uno de los aspectos que hace a
los juegos tan buenos y realistas y es
algo que se ve sobre todo con las
criaturas que rodean el juego pues a
medida que avanzas en la historia desde
él hasta fos parte 2 te darás cuenta de
que estas criaturas fueron programadas
con un apetito de sangre muy realista y
crudo pues siempre irán tras de ti pero
no dudarán en destrozar a cualquier otra
persona que se cruce en su camino sea
infectado o no
[Música]
la saga metal gear siempre ha sido un
tanto raro teniendo un par de detalles
algo únicos en la mayoría de sus juegos
y sus spin-off no iban a ser la
excepción pues metal gear rising tampoco
se salva de esto comenzando porque metal
key rising ya de por sí es un juego
bastante raro es muy bueno pero claro
esto lo podemos evidenciar en muchas
partes del juego en más de una ocasión a
lo largo de las misiones tendremos que
salvar rehenes y llevarlos sanos y
salvos a la salida pero si por alguna
razón decide salvar a uno de estos
rehenes y luego los atacas con tu espada
les quitará la ropa y tus amigos sabrán
que eres un enfermo
sus casas y vivan
j
ryder icloud sec
entera
y créanme jamás me voy a cansar de
hablar de red dead redemption 2 no solo
porque es uno de los mejores juegos que
existen sino porque a pesar de que ya
han pasado casi dos años desde su
lanzamiento aún no deja de asombrarme la
cantidad infinita de detalles que le
agregaron a su inmenso mundo y sobre
todo no deja de asombrarme lo vivos que
se sienten todos los lugares del juego
pues si te tomas el tiempo para dejar de
dispararle a medio mundo y aprecias por
un segundo notarás la increíble
inteligencia artificial de los animales
a tu alrededor pues aunque estés muy
lejos de los animales podrás verlos
jugando durmiendo o incluso cazando
otros animales
[Música]
detalles como estos son los que hacen
que red dead redemption 2 se sienta tan
real y sea uno de los mejores juegos
jamás creados y estoy dispuesto a pelear
si es necesario o más
[Música]
los remakes de resident evil 2 y 3 son
ambos unos juegazos que al igual que los
juegos originales están llenos de
escenas memorables a la par que
aterradoras una de estas escenas la
podemos hallar en el remake de resident
y hbo2 en donde podremos encontrarnos
con dos policías muertos en uno de los
pasillos de la comisaría
[Música]
y en el remake de 'resident evil' 3 le
pusieron mucha atención a la continuidad
pues en este juego podremos ver qué fue
lo que les pasó a los dos policías
pero este no es el único momento en
donde el juego le pone mucha atención a
la continuidad pues en resident evil 3
también podremos ver cómo es que marvin
el policía que ayuda al lío en el recibo
2 resulta infectado
[Música]
astros play room es el juego que viene
incluido en la playstation 5 y es de
hecho un juego muy entretenido con mucho
color mucho carisma y cientos de
referencias a las sagas de playstation
como god of war the last ojos y muchas
otras pero creo que el detalle más único
que tiene el juego es no tan sutil que
puedes perderte muy fácilmente pues no
es tan fácil de notar aunque una vez que
lo notas ya no podrás dejar de verlo y
es que en astros playground de vez en
cuando llueve pero si miras con atención
las marcas que las gotas de lluvia dejan
en el suelo son en realidad los símbolos
de playstation
[Aplausos]
voy a hacer completamente honesto con
ustedes de testour and then no fue el
juego que yo esperaba la verdad que en
mi mente yo esperaba muchos más más
grasos y monstruos y menos caminatas
pero aún así me gustó y sobre todo me
encantó la ambientación del juego no sé
hay algunos paisajes grises desértico si
experimentes que se ve tan bello
es muchísimo otra cosa que me gusta
mucho del juego es que tiene muchos
secretos y detalles por descubrir
mientras juegas uno de estos secretos lo
podrás descubrir si juegas antes randín
el día de tu cumpleaños a lo cual el
juego responderá con un pastel de
cumpleaños en tu habitación e incluso
con pequeños mensajes ocultos deseándote
un feliz cumpleaños
soy
[Música]
ah
de esta forma
sabes qué día es hoy cierto
el cumpleaños de más
el cumpleaños de bebé
ah
pero hoy es un día muy especial de todos
modos
pero no
un día especial para alguien especial
puede que lo olvidarás pero yo no
feliz cumpleaños
[Música]
creo que nunca lo he mencionado antes en
el canal pero puedes of the wild es para
mí uno de los mejores juegos de zelda
que ha habido el juego en realidad me
parece muy entretenido e la he pasado
muy bien con el juego y a medida que
jugaba más y más no puede evitar notar
cientos de detalles que me encantaron no
sólo porque las físicas del juego te
permiten hacer un millón de cosas sino
que me resultó genial ver el increíble
realismo que tienen las fuerzas
climáticas en el juego por ejemplo si
durante una tormenta llevas equipado
algún tipo de arma o accesorio de metal
causará que un rayo te golpee
[Música]
assassin's creed y unite y toma lugar a
comienzos del siglo 14 y está ambientado
en la bellísima ciudad de parís y a
pesar de que el juego es bastante normal
si se nota que en el momento de su
creación tuvieron un gran enfoque en su
ambientación pues tiene muchas
ubicaciones icónicas de la ciudad de
país de la cual destaca sobre todo la
imponente catedral de notre-dame la cual
fue reconstruida con muchísimo detalle
para este juego ahora la razón por la
que pongo este juego aquí es sencilla
como saben el 15 de abril de 2019 la
catedral de notre damme sufrió un grave
incendio que dañó gran parte de su
estructura cuando esto sucedió un soft
comenzó a regalar copias de assassin's
creed y unity para que el mundo pueda
conocer la catedral y ver lo hermosa que
era antes de el terrible incendio
al ver esto muchos expertos han afirmado
que este juego puede ser una pieza clave
para ayudar a la reconstrucción de la
catedral pues al estar representada en
el videojuego con tanto detalle puede
guiar a las personas a cargo de la
restauración y darles una idea general
de cómo lo hizo alguna vez la catedral
di lo que quieras de assassin's creed
pero gracias a su atención al detalle en
un futuro podremos volver a ver uno de
los monumentos más bellos que tiene
parís
si está en mi vídeo de la tercera parte
de detalles en videojuegos ahora es que
me parece genial cuando los videojuegos
nos dan ciertas libertades y sobre todo
cuando estas libertades involucran a la
música como podemos ver con la guitarra
totalmente funcional de él y en the last
house parte 2 y me alegró mucho darme
cuenta que este no es el único juego en
donde pasa algo así pues en half life
alix hacer primero un juego de baile y
segundo un juego de realidad virtual
tiene un mundo muy inmersivo y trabajar
a interactuar con prácticamente todo lo
que encuentres pero no es hasta que
encuentras un piano que te das cuenta de
todo lo que puedes hacer ya que el piano
no está solamente de adorno puedes
tocarlo y funcionará igualmente que un
piano normal lo que con suficiente
práctica te permitirá tocar cualquier
canción que quieras
[Música]
i
y
[Música]
de acuerdo en este voy a hacer un poco
de trampa porque no es un detalle como
tal es más un interés pero me parece
demasiado genial como para no incluir lo
super smash bros última en este momento
el último juego en la serie y reúne un
montón de personajes para que entre
todos se den en la madre cada personaje
tiene ciertos elementos especiales pero
el que más me llamó la atención fue
snail pues sí cuando estás jugando con
snake realizas una provocación' dos
veces seguidas muy rápido podrás ver los
diálogos ocultos que de snake tiene
refiriéndose al personaje contra el que
esté luchando hay un montón de diálogos
ocultos y todos son muy divertidos pero
aquí te dejo los mejores
[Música]
marcan
william layton y lo visual
y ya
snake
guau
[Música]
me guardo
dakar además a mí me sacan bananas
o no
facebook neil walker brothers o whisky
brother con cariño al hielo la ley
lalín de lo que no es no
esto amigos míos es todo por hoy sé que
muchos de ustedes han igual que a mí y
les gusta mucho la serie de detalles en
el canal así que trataré de hacer estos
vídeos un poco más seguido aunque claro
agradecería mucho el apoyo
por qué
como siempre si conoces algún otro
detalle interesante que quieres que
incluya en el siguiente vídeo déjame los
comentarios oa través de twitter
hasta la próxima
[Música]